so at 13 years old I had a UH out of  kill list  I got a hunt them down  now you got a problems right I don't  think I've ever said this before  seriously seriously this is gonna be fun  Michael and particularly become my big  brother the greatest of all time but we  call them black Jesus you're not  intimidating me we're gonna go at it  that's crazy yeah man you're about to  take your shot and on all of a sudden  boom the kiss of death you know my back  was really spasming how the hell do you  tolerate that kind of pain I play games  with the flu I play games with 102  degree fever man power they all thought  I was absolutely crazy the day me a shag  on the fist fight that's fine  oh yeah that's why I'm not backing down  listen you gotta throw me to Boston man  [ __ ] that get it off the rebound if I  miss bro you told them this it doesn't  bother you I'm finding what the hell do  you want me to do got it  [Music]  you